if you have a child your entire life  goes to the child whether you want to or  not and the thing is if I had a child  100 I'll be [ __ ] diverted to my baby  but do I want to be complete it's just  it's just interesting because like when  people list the reasons that they don't  want to have children you kind of  admitted this early on like it's why  they say modern women are selfish  because everything's about me me it's  like I don't want to give up my free  time I don't want to give up my job I  don't want to give up my mind  but there's a problem being selfish if  you're not selfish and you and you  choose to be naive and blindfolded and  act like you can do everything and you  do a half-hearted job  I I agree like I agree with what you  were saying about the nannies like I'm  not saying every single person should  have kids but usually the people that  don't have kids I would say are cell  phones